now as Americans were preparing their
turkeys and traveling to see their loved
ones this Thanksgiving probably you guys
among them the media were concerned with
something much more important leaving
the White House to spend Thanksgiving in
Florida West Palm Beach where the
president is spending his Thanksgiving
holiday president Trump has arrived at
his Golf Club that is here and so it
seems as though that is how he'll be
spending the day today all right and it
didn't stop there Newsweek published an
article with this headline how is Trump
spending Thanksgiving tweeting golfing
and more but what the media didn't know
is that the White House planned a
top-secret trip to visit US troops in
Afghanistan there's nowhere I'd rather
celebrate this Thanksgiving then right
here with the toughest strongest best
and bravest warriors on the face of the
earth we thank God for your health and
all of the things that you've done you
have very special people and you don't
even know how much the people of our
country love and respect you
well this forced the media to sort of
backtrack Newsweek updating its headline
to tweeting to quote tweeting golfing
and surprising US troops in Afghanistan
joining me now to react is Kaylee
mackaninee national press secretary for
the Trump 2020 campaign and Jennifer
hold worth Democratic strategist and
former campaign staffer for Hillary
Clinton's 2016 presidential campaign
ladies welcome aboard thank you for
joining me I appreciate it good to join
you so look it was a great Thanksgiving
for our troops in Afghanistan it was an
action that I wasn't surprised to see
the president take we know his feelings
about the military we've seen other
presidents make surprise trips to Tamura
zones etc but Kaylee there seems to be
this almost confirmation bias that the
media sees what it wants to see they're
gonna go with the negative no matter
what almost irritated when he doesn't
fit in within that narrative what's your
take on I know it's not new for us to
see this but it has been three years
what's your take on where all this is
leading it's exactly right that's what
the media does we see it repeatedly
tami every day we see some rendition of
a fake news story and it follows the
same
and they report falsely something about
President Trump or his administration
they then update it or correct it if
we're lucky if there have one iota of
honesty but they do so on Thanksgiving
evening at 6:17 p.m. as this correction
was given there was another AP story
corrected on the Friday before a 4th of
July weekend
but you're exactly right they see what
they want to see it's always the
negative about President Trump but
people see through it when ABC News
posts video from Kentucky and act as if
it's from a Syrian war zone this is what
exposes the media and the more they do
it the more the American people wake up
and get behind President Trump yeah you
know I mean this is I have to say
Jennifer it's it's an it's an
interesting dynamic because this is an
industry that all Americans have relied
on it's an important American industry
and it seems to be destroyed it's
they're destroying their own media
effectively as we move through this and
a good republic a good democracy needs a
people to question power and to be taken
seriously are you even though obviously
I'm gonna guess you don't like a
president Trump but isn't it important
for no matter who the candidates are for
American have a media that can be
trusted yes well the president has spent
the last six years denigrating any media
source that is in this network and other
other outlets that support him however
with this kind of thing can you blame
them
well Newsweek told the truth the media
was purposely not told that the
president was going to Afghanistan for a
good reason it's a security measure so
there was no way that Newsweek was going
to report that before he actually showed
up however the rest of that headline is
true the president tweeted and he played
golf on Thanksgiving he traveled to
Newmar laga what we didn't know is that
he was also traveling to Afghanistan
which I commend him for he's actually
acting presidential for once when he
goes there and greets our troops but
it's not about shaming this president
this president doesn't feel shame
otherwise he would have resigned from
office years ago I'm very proud that he
went to Afghanistan to spend time with
the troops the media didn't lie they
said exactly what he did when they were
able to say it's possible and I know you
worked with Hillary and she had some
trouble with media as well and entity
does still to some degree isn't it
possible that while you might not like
the president style that he does care
and that things that surround this
country and affect this country that it
does matter to him that that maybe we
can dissing you don't agree with style
or or that the nature of some of the
things he's done but it's so personal
this notion if he doesn't feel shame it
is that's how can you even really know
that about someone unless it's just
rhetoric for you again what I said is
that I appreciate that the president
went this Afghanistan but Trump's but
even that's a backhanded I mean that
mean there's a reason why the president
Kaylee is it goes after the media and I
would love him to have a normal
relationship with the media but they've
made it impossible at this point when we
see how they respond to every single
thing he does Kaylee I mean is there any
way we can bridge this gap when you hear
things that are so personal that are
also untrue yeah the only way to bridge
this gap is for the media to stand up
and do what they're there to do which is
to report facts to report honestly and
not to attempt to shape public opinion
but that's not going to change from the
media and why the American people love
this president is that he calls out
institutions that have long betrayed
this country the media whose approval
rating was at a historic low before
President Trump was elected not just the
Democrat Party he called out the
Republican Party and said neither of
these parties are working for the people
and then he changed the Republican Party
to be a vehicle that works for the
people and answers to their demands of
what they elect people to do he's
challenged institutions that have
betrayed the American public and they
see that and I guarantee you this
president wins with overwhelming support
that maps going to look a lot redder in
2020 but it did in 20s that's one of the
issues especially for Democrats who
don't like him is realizing that there
is something else that's occurred in the
country worth looking at but then
there's something else that we see going
on ladies liberals once again revealing
their true selves at this thing saying
the American Jennifer Jennifer one
second here really impaired Jennifer
welcome Jennifer Wayne Maryland excuse
me let's work we're gonna move on here
for one said we know you don't like him
we know you're upset we know everyone's
upset you're a young woman this is no
way to live life
it's Thanksgiving we're moving into the
holiday politics can be rough-and-tumble
but most of
who've seen this unfold over three years
remain shocked at the level of the
vitriol and that's not going to help
anyone certainly it's not going to help
your party next year in this case is an
example of that is Governor Martin
O'Malley publicly harassed Acting Deputy
Homeland secretary security secretary
Ken Cuccinelli an eyewitness to the
entire belligerent scene telling the
Ingraham angle that O'Malley instigated
the entire situation storming over
yelling at cuccinelli about the
administration's a immigration policy
Cuccinelli told Fox News quote O'Malley
pushed his way through the small group
to confront me face to face still
cursing me the president of my Italian
ancestry and he got up in my face bumped
up against me invited me to take a swing
at him at which point I said Martin one
of us has to rise above this and it's
obviously not going to be you Jennifer
was that appropriate is that something
you think is alright well I can't speak
to first-hand knowledge of what happened
but to me that sounds wildly inaccurate
from the story that was related to meet
multiple times
I know Governor O'Malley I know that
he's passionate about what he was
talking about if this administration
can't take being spoken to about their
policies that are hurting people general
politics this is obviously the other
problem is that even O'Malley's not
denying the nature of what occurred
there is a multiple witnesses Caylee
bartenders the waitstaff other people
that were in a very Mellie excuse me
it was an invitation to start a physical
fight using obscenities insulting his
Italian heritage Caylee we've seen the
encouragement to confront and and an
attack Trump supporters we've seen it
happen in public Caylee this clearly
this is a former governor it seems to
think that this is appropriate behavior
that's right and the Washington Post
reported it as you noted martin O'Malley
not denying it this is as you said a
former Democrat governor who is engaging
in this behavior and it just shows you
there is such a vile animosity on the
left that cannot get over the fact that
President Trump won it's why Sarah
Sanders was not allowed to eat dinner in
a restaurant it's why Kirsten Nielsen
was you know essentially chased out
bully out of arrest
you're on now Ken Cuccinelli - and it
all comes up the direction of Maxine
Waters it's time to quote absolutely
harass Trump officials in public places
Jennifer see this on the right this is
now Republicans do this is what the left
does we go on the ballot box they taste
Americans Americans are seeing that
judging for themselves Jennifer I've
been told that an Ingram angle producer
was in that pub just after the event and
confirmed with a number of witnesses
that were there including the waitstaff
would it be so difficult to be able to
say that was wrong as opposed to denying
it and pretending it didn't happen I'm
gonna take your word that he threatened
physical violence that is absolutely
never the answer but if an
administration official can't take being
spoken to about these policy but that's
that's not what happened here and this
is the issue this is not what this very
television there I didn't speak to
Governor O'Malley we have C this is why
the Democrats have such trouble ladies
thank you very much for joining me I do
appreciate it this is the problem right
I mean this is this is the nature of
what we've got happening in society and
there's even a refusal to admit it by
the way I want to say for Kaley many of
you may not know she has just had a baby
she is a new mom Kaley congratulations I
saw it on social media a really
beautiful event this little Blake isn't
that right that's right and I saw your
message on Twitter thank you so much
we're so blessed this holiday season
well congratulations I mean this is it's
you know with everything going on this
is the entire a good reminder here with
this segment life matters enjoying your
life being able to deal with certain
elements of reality being political is
fine but it's also the fact that that
family matters and being able to you
know deal with the the nature of what's
occurring and you know embrace the
wonderful things and condemn the things
that aren't so wonderful all right Kaley
thank you so much congratulations thank
you